when heather jane first began
experiencing symptoms of long covid she
had no idea what was wrong my acute
phase of covid was in the very early
first wave april 2020 and so
um you know
for me it was really hard to understand
what was happening to my body it's
estimated that more than one-third of
covid19 sufferers will report continued
symptoms like fatigue or breathing
problems for months after their initial
infection has resolved and now
researchers out of australia are
beginning to better understand who has
been impacted we found
when we looked at the blood and as well
as
immune cells within these participants
that there was a dysfunction
within the immunological pathways the
discovery of a biomarker within a
patient's blood could not only help
develop a better tool to diagnose the
illness but could lead to better
treatments as well while researchers
still don't know what causes long covet
a leading theory is that parts of the
virus can linger in the body causing
inflammation triggered by a prolonged
immune system response and according to
another recent study that inflammation
can cause neurological symptoms for up
to nine months young people who survived
through cover 19 despite the fact that
their mind didn't have any symptom or
have the only mild symptoms months later
they still had
a very
mild impaired impairment in memory and
attention while there is still much to
learn about this condition that for some
can be debilitating heather jane is
trying to maintain hope i'm a very
different person now and i've been
forever changed by this experience two
years after her first infection the
toronto woman is now recovering from
covid yet again
unsure of how this second round will
impact her long-term health heather urex
west global news calgary